Ukraine's long expected
counter-offensive is now fully underway
in its Southeastern regions
and Russia has pushing back launching
several drone attacks targeting
Ukrainian targets but Moscow is also
fighting another battle on the home
front
its defense minister Sergey shoigo has
ordered all military volunteer units
sign a contract with the government
Ministries
the order grants all volunteers the
right to enter into individual contracts
either with volunteer units or with the
ministry of Defense as contract
servicemen the order expands the
possibilities of Manning the units of
the joint group of forces by both the
servicemen and volunteers
the defense minister wants to centralize
all military activities under his
command but that's not going down well
with the head of Russia's Wagner
mercenary group yev Guinea pregosian who
strongly criticized Russia's military
and its leaders in recent weeks he has
now seized this latest move to launch
further attacks against joygo
unfortunately the majority of military
units do not have such efficiency and
that is precisely because of Choi ku's
inability to properly manage the
military formations therefore what he
writes or orders only applies to the
ministry of defense and those within the
ministry of Defense
precaution has even accused the Russian
army of laying landmines to blow up his
troops as they withdrew from Ukraine's
besieged city of bakmud and the personal
relationship between pregosian and
President Vladimir Putin could also
further complicate matters because for
many it's unclear if bregozian is
implementing Putin's agenda or if he's a
rival who is now becoming a threat to
the Kremlin